aquí en el punto para aprender
ecuaciones diferenciales es poder
usarlas para eventualmente modelar algo
de la vida real todo lo que hemos hecho
hasta el momento es crear un conjunto de
herramientas que nos permitan
resolverlas pero eso se debe a que las
ecuaciones diferenciales pueden escribir
diferentes sistemas a los que
eventualmente podremos modelar y sabemos
que en la vida real no todos son
funciones continuadas bonitas por eso en
los próximos vídeos vamos a hablar sobre
funciones que son un poco más
discontinuas de lo que estamos
acostumbrados a ver en nuestras clases
tradicionales de cálculo y la primera
que veremos es la función escalón
unitario se escribe como un subíndice de
t
y se define como
bueno se define como 0 cuando t es menor
que el subíndice que yo haya escrito
aquí en este caso sé cuándo t es menor
que se y se define como uno cuando t es
mayor o igual que sé y si ustedes
quisieran graficar a esto lo pueden
hacer realmente no es nada difícil
voy a dibujar mi récord de nado mi eje x
aquí en un bonito color verde
voy a poner mi eje y aquí
cuando hablemos de las transformadas de
la plaza que es a lo que nos vamos a
referir aquí solo nos van a interesar
los valores de la función cuando t es
mayor a 0 de todas maneras nuestra
definición de la transformada de la
plaza es la integral que va de 0 a
infinito por lo que siempre vamos a
estar trabajando con la parte positiva
de esta función de cualquier manera
vamos a tener el valor de 0 hasta que
lleguemos a algún valor a nuestro valor
c en este caso entonces vamos a tener un
cero hasta que llegamos hace y el c
tenemos un salto como si tuviera un
escalón de ahí viene el nombre vamos a
ponerlo aquí en este punto y ese es
nuestro valor 1 en este caso de la
función y a partir de aquí todo el valor
siguiente va a ser igual a un 1 pero
bueno ustedes me pueden decir oye me
acabas de decir que vamos a usar
ecuaciones diferenciales para modelar
cosas y qué me sirve ver esto bueno en
el mundo real existen situaciones en la
que tenemos un valor y de repente ese
valor salta o brinca aunque no hay nada
que tenga un cambio tan brusco como esto
pero si tenemos situaciones en donde
podemos ver que hay un valor que no pasa
nada se mantiene ese valor y de repente
llega un punto en el que pregunta
y esta función es una muy buena
aproximación analítica para modelar este
tipo de comportamiento siempre que
estamos viendo estas ecuaciones
diferenciales de manera analítica vamos
a tratar de encontrar un modelo puro de
algo aunque eventualmente veremos que
ningún modelo define o describe
perfectamente una situación del mundo
real pero nos ayuda a describirlo
suficientemente bien como para que
podamos analizar pero bueno vamos a
borrar esto de aquí para continuar con
nuestro análisis bueno la primera
pregunta al respecto es qué tal si algo
no se comporta exactamente como esto qué
tal si yo quisiera hacer
si yo quisiera hacer unas funciones
escalón un poquito más sofisticadas
qué tal si yo quisiera construir algo
que se viera como esto
digamos que esto está es mi hijo y éste
es mi eje x y digamos que quiero
construir algo que luce más o menos en
otro color lo voy a poner este es un 2
hasta que llegó hasta que llegó el valor
de pi
valor de pi 3.14 16
cuando lee este valor va a continuar
siendo ser como puedo yo construir esta
función usando lo que sé de mi función
escalón unitario muy bien pensemos un
poco al respecto
qué pasaría si yo reescribir a esto de
manera que escribo
2 - la función escalón unitario que es
un es mi función a escalón unitario que
va a comenzar desde el valor de pi y es
una función de t si yo definiera esto
como mi función ft bueno como está
definida esta función escalón sería
igual a 1 cuando llegue al valor de pi
pero queremos que tenga el valor de 2
así que aquí le vamos a multiplicar por
un 2 y ya con esto debe de funcionar
mientras tengamos un valor que sea menor
a pie mientras sea un valor menor a pi
éste va a atender un cero así que la
función se va a evaluar en dos pero en
cuanto lleguemos a que te sea igual a pi
recordemos que es nuestra c en este
ejemplo y en cuanto llegue a este valor
nuestra función escalón se va a volver 1
por lo que va a ser dos menos 2 igual a
0 y nuestra función a partir de este
punto va a ser igual a 0
todo esto está muy bien pero qué pasaría
si ustedes necesitarán regresar un paso
que el lugar en lugar de tener la
función como esto
vamos a estar quitando esto voy a borrar
esto de aquí quiero que vuelva a brincar
mi función quiero que vuelva a tomar el
valor de 2 después o cuando llegue a
otro valor más al reiba de pi
digamos doble de pi como construiremos
esta función y no tenemos que salte a
cualquier lugar queremos que regrese al
valor de 2
bueno pues podemos agregar otra función
a escala ahora esta va a ser cero
durante todo el tiempo pero va a saltar
a dos en el momento en el que llegue a
dos pi así que en este caso con nuestra
nueva función escalón nuestra se va a
ser igual a dos pi y recordemos que la
función escalón solita saltaría 1 y lo
que queremos es que salte a 2 así que la
vamos a multiplicar por 2 y de esta
manera ustedes pueden crear sus propias
funciones arbitrarias en las que pueden
ir brincando de arriba a abajo como
ustedes lo prefieran simplemente usando
diferentes combinaciones lineales de
esta función escalón pero ahora vamos a
hacer algo todavía un poco más
sofisticado digamos que tengo una
función que luce así
más o menos así aquí está de nuevo mi
eje
mi eje de mi eje x y digamos que mi
función
efe dt este es x bueno no no de hecho
aquí debe ser una t porque mis funciones
están con respecto a t
así que esta va a ser efe dt y aquí voy
a dibujar algo completamente arbitraria
digamos que es pongo esta curva así
qué tal si yo modelar a esto de la
siguiente manera este es mi ft
y si yo modelar a este sistema de la
siguiente manera
digamos que se va a mantener en cero
hasta cierto valor se va a mantener en
cero hasta que llegue al valor que es
nuestra sed
y aquí se empieza a elevar nuestra
función
cuando llega a ser y comienza a hacer
algo así
bueno de hecho lo que tenemos aquí es
una combinación en donde se tiene cero y
después se tiene un desplazamiento a ft
llegándose se desplaza hacia este lado
como podríamos modelar esta función
amarilla pues es la misma función que la
función verde de ft pero tiene un valor
de 0 y en el momento en el que llegue
hace es que se da a esta función
esta función verde puede estar así o
puede haber continuado más o menos así
pero nosotros lo único que hicimos es
desplazar la de aquí para acá y dejar en
cero todo lo que estaba antes de ser
bueno como es que hacemos esto bueno
ustedes aprendieron en sus clases de
álgebra o de pre cálculo que para
desplazar una función porsche hacia la
derecha sólo tenemos que reemplazar
nuestra t con una p - por lo que nuestra
función amarilla quedaría efe dt en
menos y para asegurarnos de que esto
está bien lo que voy a hacer es
imaginarme qué pasaría si te fuera igual
a c
es igual a c c - se va a ser igual a 0
así que voy a tener efe de 0 cuando te
es igual hace el valor de la función va
a ser equivalente a nuestra función ft
que está en color verde lo que tiene
sentido así que si tenemos uno más
arriba de c si esto hace más uno
entonces vamos a tener
efe de c + 1 - c + gm se nos va a quedar
efe de 1 por lo que va a ser el mismo
valor de f de uno solo que desplazado lo
cual tiene sentido ya que si tenemos
este número f 1 aquí pues va a ser
equivalente al que está de este otro
lado sólo que desplazado un espacio de c
y bueno como yo desplace esta función
pues sentiría ustedes podrían tener toda
esta parte que continúa abajo de c sin
embargo yo lo estoy definiendo que esta
función va a mostrarse a partir del
valor de ce lo que está antes vale 0 así
que como voy a poner en ceros todo lo
que está antes de ser bueno creo que es
obvio ya que comencé este vídeo
hablándoles de la función escalón
unitario así
qué pasaría si yo multiplico mi función
escalón unitario por esto que va a pasar
bueno voy a tener una nueva función que
va a ser mi función escalón se de t
x efe dt - e
qué es lo que va a suceder
hasta que llegamos al valor de c todo va
a ser cero antes de mi valor se en el
momento en el que llego a mi valor se va
a tener el valor de mi función t menos
en el momento que yo alcanzó el valor se
me funciona escalón se convierte en 1
esto se vuelve uno y nos queda entonces
la función de tm
y cómo te va a ser aún mayor pues va a
restar se está menos ce por lo que nos
va a quedar el valor de la función
evaluada de 0 en adelante esta es una
función construida bastante útil y en un
momento vamos a ver la transformada de
la plaza de esto y así ustedes podrán
apreciar porque esto es una función muy
útil pero al menos ustedes ya saben de
qué se trata y cómo es que desplazan a
una función y pone en ceros todo lo que
se encuentra antes de este punto de
desplazamiento y ya que les acabo de
decir que esta es una función muy útil
deberíamos agregar la transformada de la
plaza de esta función en nuestra tabla
de transformadas de la plaza así que
vamos a hacerlo vamos a hacer la
transformada de la plaza
esto de nuestra función escalón se de te
vamos a hacerlo de momento en forma
general y en los siguientes vídeos
veremos cómo aplicar esto pero al menos
debemos comprobar por nosotros mismos
cuál es la transformada de la plaza de
esto bueno la transformada de la plaza
de cualquier cosa recordemos que es la
integral impropia de 0 a infinito de a
la menos 7 x la función lo que pusimos a
transformar en este caso nuestra función
escalón de cdt multiplicada por la
función
efe dt menos c de menos c
dt y esto pues en general se ve bastante
difícil de evaluar
pero quizás podríamos encontrar alguna
forma de sustituir algo para poder
apreciar esto así que vamos a hacer una
sustitución aquí
déjenme elegir una variable bonita bueno
podríamos usar x ya que no estamos
ocupando x en ningún lugar aquí x
algunas clases presentan estos alfabetos
en latín que por sí solos ya son
difíciles de comprender y hacen que el
aprendizaje sea un poco más complejo o
lo que vamos a usar aquí una x normal
común y corriente y aquí nuestra x va a
ser igual a t menos vamos a usarla para
sustituir
si tenemos latte en ambos lados podremos
decir que t es igual a equis massey
vamos a ver qué podemos hacer con esa
sustitución ahora si obtenemos la
derivada en ambos lados de esta igualdad
vamos a tener de x va a ser igual a
bueno de hecho es de x con respecto a de
t eso va a ser igual a 1 porque se es
una constante si multiplicamos ambos
lados por de t nos va a quedar que de x
+ igualdad de t y esta es una buena
sustitución bueno como vamos a tener
entonces nuestra integral con esta
sustitución esta integral va a hacer
cuando te es igual a 0 y cuando te tiene
infinito que pasa cuando te es igual a
cero qué pasa con esta x cuando ésta t
es igual a cero nuestra x va a ser igual
a menos bueno de hecho antes de ver esta
parte permíteme regresarme un paso
anterior a éste aunque podríamos
continuar haciendo lo que estamos
haciendo pero creo que sería un poquito
más complicado la explicación podemos
simplificarlo bastante antes de entrar a
este punto vamos a regresar a nuestra
integral antes de que quisiéramos
nuestra sustitución vamos a tomar
integral impropia de 0 a infinito y
vamos a hermano como luce esta integral
como se ve esta función cuando es 0
tenemos esta función escalón aquí por lo
que toda esta expresión va a ser igual a
toda esta expresión va a ser 0 antes de
llegar al valor de c debido a que
estamos hablando de una función escalón
unitario todo esto por definición va a
ser igual a 0 hasta que llegamos al
valor c así que podemos decir que
esencialmente no tenemos que tomar la
integrada cuando t es igual a 0
hasta cuando te tiene infinito sino
cuando t es igual a c así que vamos a
reescribir esta integral podemos
reescribir nuestra integral desde que t
es igual a c hasta que te tiende a
infinito
al menos siete por uno sé que es nuestra
función escalón unitario que llega al
valor de ce por la función de t menos
dt y aquí les quiero indicar que esta
función a escalón unitario que tenemos
aquí ya no nos es útil ya fue
incorporada dentro de estos elementos de
la integral por lo que la podemos quitar
de aquí y quiero que esto quede muy
claro lo que hice yo aquí fue modificar
nuestro límite inferior de la integral
de 0 a c y bueno ustedes se dieron
cuenta porque lo hice al analizar el
comportamiento de la función escala
unitario en este caso si mantenemos esta
función aquí va a ser igual a 0 hasta
que lleguemos al valor de c y por
definición la integral es el área bajo
una curva aquí antes del valor de s no
tendríamos curva alguna así que todo
esto va a ser igual a 0 para todos los
valores menores a c y una vez que
lleguemos al valor de c esta integral va
a ser igual a ala menos act por f
dt - c
hasta este momento es cuando vamos a
poder tener ya nuestra función así que
si queremos encontrar el área bajo la
curva todo esto va a ocurrir a partir
del valor de ce en adelante así que en
lugar de integrar desde t igual a 0
hasta t igual infinito comenzamos a
integrar cuando t es igual a c hasta que
éste tiende a infinito y a partir del
valor de nuestra función escalón
unitario va a ser igual a 1 en todos los
rangos de valores de t a partir de c así
que bien podemos ignorarlo podemos
simplificar nuestra integral la
integrada de t igual hace hasta t que
tiende a infinito
al menos siete por efe
dt dt
y esto nos simplifica bastante las
operaciones por eso es que quise hacer
la sustitución primero en lugar está
trabajando con las integrales como lo
estábamos haciendo lo hubiéramos podido
hacer pero iba a ser un poquito más
complicado pero bueno ahora regresemos a
la parte en la que usamos la sustitución
de x igual a t menos c
no está integral se va a convertir
cuando t es igual a c qué pasa con x a
pues x es igual a 0 y cuando te tiende a
infinito bueno pues va a ser un número
muy grande - se va a seguir siendo un
número muy grande por lo que aquí sigue
siendo infinito
y esto va a ser la integral de al menos
ese pero en lugar de t vamos a sustituir
el valor de x y xi dijimos que x es
igual a tm no sé entonces x + c
y ahora lo vamos a multiplicar por la
función de tm no sé pero vamos a usar la
sustitución x ac m no se quede en x
dt es igual a de x así que sustituimos
aquí de x
y ahora esto comienza a verse
interesante esto es igual pues va a ser
igual a nuestra integral impropia de 0 a
infinito
y permíteme expandir un poco esto de la
menos s x menos s pulse por fx de x
bueno y ahora esto que es igual
vamos a factorizar esto está ese desee
que no tiene que ver con nuestra
integral ya que no tiene ningún término
en x
así que vamos a reescribir todo esto de
manera que nos queda la integral
impropia de 0 infinito
lo escribo aquí para que no se confunden
este término de no vamos a escribir en
colores diferentes
al menos ese por equis
x el ala - sc
tienen una base en común si yo
multiplicar a estos dos pues simplemente
sumaría los exponentes así que es lo
mismo x f x de x
y si vemos este término de la ccc es un
valor constante no tiene ningún término
en x por lo que lo podemos sacar de
nuestra integral y nos quedaría entonces
y al menos es ese x la integral de 0 a
infinito de ala menos sx-f x de x
bueno recordemos que es lo que estamos
haciendo aquí
lo que estamos haciendo es encontrar la
transformada de la plaza de nuestra
función escalón unitario y dese el valor
de c
es una función de t x una función
desplazada de t - c
y ahora vemos que esto es igual a lo que
acabamos de encontrar recordamos que
hicimos una sustitución y simplificamos
y nos queda
a la - sc por una integral de 0 a
infinito
al menos s x por fx
x hoy lo escribo mejor de x
esto que es suena interesante no a qué
les parece conocido esto pues esta es la
transformada de la plaza de equis
recordemos que la transformada de la
plaza de una función de o de una función
en x puede ser cualquiera transformada
de la plaza de ft es igual a la integral
impropia de 0 a infinito
a la menos st por ft dt
si aquí sustituimos la t por equis nos
queda esta otra función
puedo poner x puedo poner no importa
estos son letras y aquí debe ser una que
en lugar de una x
de la misma manera pude haber escrito
la transformada de la plaza de efe
igual a la integral impropia de 0 a
infinito de ala menos s porque por efe
de y deje aquí pueden haber puesto
cualquier otra letra cuando hacemos la
integral ustedes han visto que estas
variables desaparecen y nos queda todo
en términos de s esto va a ser igual a
una función de f mayúscula de s así que
esto es interesante porque tenemos la
transformada de la plaza de ft
multiplicado por un factor escalar así
que ahora podemos mostrar que la
transformada de la plaza la transformada
de la plaza de nuestra función escalón
unitario dt multiplicado por la función
de menos se va a ser igual
al menos es ese
que es la misma cd acá x la transformada
de las opciones no sé qué está pasando
con esto la transformada de la plaza de
ft
y esto va a ser igual a la menos sc por
la transformada de la plaza
de efe dt aquí ya está mejor escrito
nuestro resultado excelente ya tenemos
este resultado pero qué significa que
podemos hacer con esto
bueno imaginemos que queremos encontrar
la transformada de la plaza de nuestra
función escalón que comienza en pie dt y
digamos que
lo multiplicamos por el seno el seno de
t - y lo estamos desplazando esta
cantidad no sé qué está pasando con esta
pluma creo que voy a tener que pasar
esto para ver qué está pasando ok
mil disculpas porque tuve que hacer una
pausa aquí ya que estaba teniendo
problemas con mi tableta digital de
dibujo pero ahora vamos a reescribir los
resultados que acabamos de obtener la
transformada de la plaza de nuestra
función a escalón unitario que comienza
en su dt multiplicada por una función
que está siendo desplazada por un valor
ce a la derecha va a ser igual
a la menos c por s por la transformada
de la plaza de f de la función efe dt
sin el desplazamiento este fue nuestro
gran descubrimiento en este vídeo y esto
puede parecer un resultado muy extraño
sin embargo lo podemos aplicar como
podemos hacerlo y aquí es donde estaba
yo cuando me tableta la pluma de mi
tableta comenzó a portarse mal
formada de la plaza de nuestra función
escalón unitario a partir de pi x
el seno de t desplazado a la derecha y
esto sería igual a
a las menos
en este caso es pink así que es menos
por s por la transformada de la plaza de
nuestra función sin el desplazamiento de
seno de t
y por supuesto nosotros ya sabemos cuál
es la transformada de la plaza de seno
de t es uno entre s cuadrada más uno así
que la transformada de la plaza de toda
esta cosa que se ve bastante complicada
ahora sabemos qué es esto multiplicado
por esto
o lo escribimos a la menos people s / s
cuadrada + 1 en los siguientes vídeos
haremos un par de ejemplos más al
respecto y estaremos yendo y viniendo
entre los dominios de s y de t al igual
que seguiremos trabajando con la
transformada de la plaza y les voy a
mostrar por qué esto es útil para tomar
e invertir varias transformadas de la
plaza